[Music]
right
my take on a barbecue shrimp now i know
there's so many different variations but
whilst here
i thought i'd do a beautiful quick and
easy barbecue
sauteed shrimp with the most amazing
pickled asparagus these have been peeled
and deveined really important the vein
is just getting out of that little sack
from the back there like that
peeing them i like leaving the ends on
there especially when you pick them up
and eat them
and more importantly the heads on that's
always a great sign of an amazing shrimp
with their heads on and the flame inside
those heads
are second to none now up here
um it's the start of the picture of my
asparagus i love pickling because it's a
really nice way of eating
something highly acidic with something
so sweet and delicious
so a cup of vinegar brought up to the
boil
a cup of sugar brought up to the boil
dissolve the sugar really important
a pinch of salt in there and then
i've got some really nice fresh dill
okay just bring them up
and then from there a little bit of
lemon okay
again really nice way of making it
last and the good thing about pickling
vegetables is they can eat any time
how do i cook the asparagus you know
sometimes they don't even need cooking
but what i like to do is get a nice hot
nonstick pan
salt that pan really important i want to
toast the asparagus
okay so we're going to sort of get
asparagus in there and scorch them
just like that again
scorch them and that just sort of
brings out the flavor lightly sauteed
i'm not cooking them all the way through
the cooking syrup has just come up
to the boil turn that off and let that
cool down
with the asparagus and give them a nice
little seasoning
a touch of old bay just a touch it's
almost like a sort of
hot spicy pickle
but look at the asparagus now look
what's happening to them sort of
going that really nice dark nutty
color and the flavor on them is
beautiful
now once they start to really toast like
that especially with the spice on there
take your little jar take them out
and literally just pop them in to the
jar
okay and
like i said they last forever
they don't go off they're pickling them
and
i always find by toasting them first
it's a really nice crunch
to asparagus look at that have flavor
on there especially the seasoning it's
so beautiful
it's a really nice accompaniment to
serve
there you go room for one more down
there
in january take your
liquid and then just literally pull that
over
nice and carefully
up to the top nice
okay okay let them
cool down completely set them in the
fridge it's got this really nice
delicious
pick-me-up snack but it's great
accompaniment especially
for the bbq shrimp now when it comes to
the shrimp
these things cook so quickly so get
ready
so what i mean by getting ready is get
your slots
get your garlic and just literally
slice them not too thin by the way too
thin they'll burn quickly so just
down
again garlic not too thin
from there just bring that up a little
bit
okay and snap them all but just
open up a little bit you'll see why it's
so beautiful
nice and hot again this is a very very
quick
action so shrimp nicely seasoned
seasoned with some salt a little bit of
old bay
and quite generous on the seasoning
don't forget i'm gonna roll it around
season the heads as well like i said the
flavor in those heads is incredible
from there a little touch of olive oil
and get some color
on the shrimp first lay them down
beautiful into the pan at the top of the
pan and work your way down
okay now
these things literally take 60 seconds
each side
again seasoning on the other side
lightly
and then from there i want to
get that old bay in there as well see
the shrimp tightening up
a touch of olive oil before i turn them
i'm going to start sprinkling my
shallots
and my garlic all the way around the
outside
okay the chocolate garlic are really
important part of this dish
don't tell the shrimp yet i'm going to
turn them once it's really important
sometimes you have the work ingredients
in the pan like that so how you don't
want them breaking up
but now look what's happening the shrimp
are starting to colour beautifully
around the outside show my butter just
tiny little speckles of butter in there
time just take them off and take those
little buds off
and literally pull them down and season
with the time
i've got some nice fresh little plushies
of dill there as well
now it's time to turn the shrimp
beautiful look at the color of these
shrimp
amazing amazing
you feel more about now literally
60 seconds each side slots
cooking nicely
and then a touch more butter
and then we'll lay the pan with a little
touch
of pressure now that's going to get a
really nice
and an amazing sort of caramelized
flavor
beautiful now for the formula stand back
thumb at the end
[Music]
your eyebrows now literally before they
come out of the pan
take your lemon and
off and squeeze that all over
[Music]
so beautiful simple execution
when it comes to serving in
you can see now why we sliced
everything so nice and thinly
[Music]
now
now what do we use to mop up that
incredible flavor underneath all those
shrimp
a little bit of a french baguette and
what i want to do is just literally
turn these in half
lightly toast that pan with a touch of
oil
again gently season it spice world
in a way that the old bay the creole
occasion you know there's lots of
debates there's crawl in the center it's
cajun in the province
it's everywhere so get that oil nice and
hot
and then literally get your bread in
and just toast that nicely beautiful
both sides nice and generous
now this goes a long way when you get to
the bottom of that bowl the flavor
from the shallots and the garlic and the
butter and the vodka and the touch
of olive oil is so tasty so you want
something really nice to mop it up with
beautiful french bread oh my god so good
toast
so bread
beautifully done and then how do you
how do you find that balance you know
take your asparagus out and just slice
them in half
there's still a really nice crunch but
it's a sort of spicy crunch
and it really is an amazing
accompaniment
to go with your beautiful shrimp
honestly so easy let the ingredients do
the talking
and there we have the most amazing
barbecue shrimp northern style with some
beautiful french bread
and delicious vibrant pickled asparagus
enjoy let me know in the comments what
you think of that amazing dish and if
you missed uncharted
trust me you can watch it on the link
below or
on the nat geo app